the workshop and
i think initiative is definitely a very
long-term
friend of simon's and he has visited
assignments many times already and today
he's going to give a virtual talk on
computationally efficient alternatives
to mimax optimization so without further
ado yeah you should see you can you can
the stage is all yours
thank you so much uh
uh for the invitation and the
introduction
um while i'm delighted to give this talk
i must also say that you know what is
happening in the world is very tragic
and perhaps
um
gives some more motivation for us to
think about
uh various things in life besides
research but maybe
think more carefully about adversaries
which is what this talk is going to be
about
um so the message of this talk is
actually very simple we are going to
explore
uh min max optimization problems which
are used to model
many
situations in machine learning economics
theoretical computer science game theory
to model
learning
or decision making in the presence of
adversaries
uh it's it's a very important problem uh
however unlike its uh
it's its relatives minimization
um there has been some
issues related to try to find out uh
what should be a notion of
a solution here
and in this talk i will propose a notion
which is
called greedy adversarial equilibrium
which is something
that we came up with with oren mangubi
in a paper in 2021
and
it is a restriction on the max player
and what it does is allows us to
define our
new notions of equilibria which we then
show
exist under
less strict conditions and also can be
found efficiently
okay so let's uh let's start this talk
from
uh from from the connection between
learning and minimization i guess
everybody here
would be
bored in the first few minutes of the
talk but let me just do that anyways in
case there is someone who's not
quite sure
uh where i'm coming from
so
one of the one of the key uh successes
in the last
few decades has been reducing many
machine learning tasks to
uh optimization or minimization
where the functions that we want to
minimize encode the data from which we
want to learn from
and with the availability of really
large-scale real-world data sets along
with
uh our ability to
do non-trivial computations
um we have made a lot of success we have
achieved a lot of success in this in
this area
um i guess
um we have been looking at historically
the machine learning community has been
looking at a
non-trivial
functions which which can encode the
loss uh
giving rise to various non-convex
objectives
which are in general and be hard to
optimize
however there are many efficient uh
notions of local minimization
which exists for non-convex optimization
and let me let me mention one of them
which is actually relevant to this talk
this is the notion of epsilon local
minima
uh
presented by nesterov and poliak in
2006.
so for a given function f
which is not necessarily convex anymore
we say that a point x star is a second
order
epsilon local minimum
if it satisfies the following two
properties one is that its gradient at
the point x star is small less than
epsilon
mimicking or trying to mimic the fact
that if it's zero then it's a stationary
point and the second is that it's
hessian at this point x star
is
not too small or the eigenvalues of the
hessian are not too small in particular
all eigenvalues of the hessian are at
least minus square root epsilon so this
relation between epsilon and square root
epsilon is not quite clear from this
definition but it is important for their
definition something that i'm uh i would
be unable to explain in this talk but
let's just
think of
this definition if it if it's if it's
helpful you can also introduce two
different parameters here epsilon and
delta
so um
the key point uh which this definition
seems to be useful for is that at any
point which is not an epsilon local
minimum in this sense
one can decrease the value of the
function
by epsilon in taking about poly1 over
epsilon steps
so the key number to
focus here is on one over epsilon and
things like l and logar logarithm in the
dimensions also important so l is the
lipschitz constant of the function
and
yeah but there's no assumption on
convexity here
um
so
using this uh uh you know using this
idea an estrava and polyarc uh poliak
gave a algorithm which runs in
polynomial one over epsilon l and log d
and subsequently there have been
improvements by various groups of people
some of them in berkeley
and probably present in the
simon semester
that's happening right now
um
so the story of
local minima in the case of minimization
has uh had a good run
so we're going to switch and try to see
what happens when we want to do
something more than just learning from
data data that we're learning from
uh may not be accurate or our
assumptions about the data might not be
accurate in which case
uh the question would be how to model
um
the data and and and so what what are
the possibilities well one is that the
data could be noisy and the second is
that the data could be adversarially
perturbed
now these are of course two of the many
possibilities that you can imagine
but the question that arises is how does
the learner continue to learn from such
data
under the presence of such
perturbative channels
and um
you know these these uh these
adversaries uh arise of course in in uh
simple
uh
just the basic machine learning problems
but also uh in other problems such as uh
privacy where there may be a
uh
where the data might be perturbed on
purpose to protect the privacy of the
individual
or
the data might have uh systemic biases
which are encoded and
whose nature might not be known
so
min max optimization has been used
as one of the solution concepts
to do learning in this
in this setting
and the traditional framework
uh considers functions so it will model
the learning problem in the presence of
an adversary
by
two sets of variables and a function
one set of variables x is
the set of variables or the model
parameters that belong to the original
learning problem
and one set of variables y
typically belongs to the adversaries
who can
[Music]
either perturb the data or do something
else
and this gives rise to functions f x y
which depend both on x variables and y
variables the goal of the x player
is to minimize the function
f and the goal of the
y player is to to maximize it
so this is uh and there is a sequence
here so main max
you know this is uh
you know
it's not the same as maximum
so
in this setting i would say uh
the case of convex concave
functions f
is somewhat better studied
and and
and there's a lot of works
uh but in many machine learning
applications uh that
we would like
to use this f is non-convex in x and
non-convex non-concave and y
so
while this model is really uh
you know
great
it it is very flexible and very powerful
it's not clear whether we can define
even locally convergent algorithms for
these
uh these models
yeah i guess one should keep in mind
that you know at the end
at least from where i come from i mean
the goal is to
solve the original learning problem in
the presence of adversaries
and min max optimization
[Music]
is one particular way to do it
so
and i guess this is where this talk is
going to be heading that we are going to
be focusing more on this and
be willing to relax this notion of
min max optimization to something
different which we're going to talk
about
so i guess here
in the audience everybody has
hopefully seen the example of gans
degenerative adversarial networks
which
which have been used
which have been used for a variety of
tasks
and are kind of the quintessential
to min max optimization to a machine
learning community because the way they
were
formulated it is in the min max setting
although there are variants of it as
well so don't talk too much about gans
[Music]
given that this is a
40 minute or so talk
but in case you wanted to see a
practical example this is
one motivated motivating example from
unsupervised learning
so
let's talk a little bit about uh local
equilibrium from in max optimization
problems
there have been many many priorities
to define
a notion of an epsilon local min max
point
and roughly
several of them try to to to to say a
point you know x star y star
is epsilon local minimum min max if
uh y star is some kind of a local
maximum of f
for a fixed x star
and x star is an epsilon local minimum
for f for a given fixed y star
so this is in in this sense it's
actually a true equilibrium
and something really
um
satisfying uh
in the sense that if
the
if we fix y star
sorry if we fix x star and the max
player can only use
local algorithms to
uh to improve their payoffs
this definition makes sense
and same for the
for the main player
however there are many
even simple examples
and complexity reasons why
this
may be a tricky notion
to make computationally efficient for
one
such points may not exist and there are
examples
uh in particular in paper by
jane netripali and jordan
and even under the presence of
even when one can show that they exist
through some existential
results they may be computationally hard
to find
as was shown in a paper by das kalakis
kulakis and zampatakis
in 2021
while i don't have time to go into the
details of why these things don't exist
one of the issues seems to be
that learning agents who can only make
local predictions
uh so you know these notions of local
maximum and minimum
are what i'm referring to here
are generally unable to predict their
opponent's responses
and this leads to a convergence problems
and many algorithms such as gradient
dissenters
as
this gif on my
title slide was showing so
there is this issue of non-convergence
it can spiral out
and
may cycle and various other behavior
so a big body of work has focused on
identifying conditions under which they
can guarantee
and find
local
min max
points
um
yeah so this is a list it's it's it's
not at all comprehensive so apologies if
i missed out your paper i know there is
a huge and rapidly growing body of work
in this
in this
in this area
um
some of the assumptions include that you
know the function is bilinear
uh as was made by the skull locus and
panagias
um
or
we have access to some specific and
special starting points
as uh was the case in the paper of hoy
zelda mouser
onto thiner nestler hawkwriter in 2017
or that the function is concave in one
variable for instance
um
yeah so there have been uh there's been
really a lot of work
so why
you know so so okay so these are one can
argue that these are theoretical issues
whether actually there is a problem in
the real
real applications and the answer is yes
there is a problem it's not just a
matter of
so this is one of the problems in
machine learning where it's not just a
matter of using theory to explain
something
but actually using theory to come up
with and
go beyond the issues that currently
exist which even
non-theoreticians are
somewhat unable to answer or address
so
um
i guess in terms of gans and i'm not
sure how popular guns are these days
but uh
gans uh you know have shown to have
cycling behavior they so for example
this is a simple
case where there are four gaussians
centered at these red points
very small variants and
you can see that
when we use something like gradient
descent ascent
it learns a mode but then it forgets it
and goes to another mode and
and so on so it starts showing this
cycling behavior
there are other issues such as uh
um
you know
um
this non-convergence uh or instability
that has also been observed
with these
uh with these simple algorithms
okay so now coming to this talk um
the key idea which
which i mentioned in the beginning of
the talk
is to change the model from min max
optimization
to something where
the max player is a bit more restricted
so the max player will be
computationally restricted the max
player remember is the adversary
and
what we do is to
in a nutshell say that
the adversary
will only move to a new point
if
it can see a path from the current point
to a new point
which is
increasing its objective function by at
least some amount
okay so this is the conceptual uh
this is really the key takeaway from
this talk
now
why
would this make sense well this doesn't
make sense first of all in every
situation where the adversary
can if you if one is trying to model a
very powerful adversary which can jump
from a point to other point
having access to magical you know magic
computational powers
uh this this notion will not uh ensure
you against that
but if the adversary
is using
algorithms themselves and in particular
greedy algorithms
uh such as sgd or gradient descent and
so on
[Music]
we will see that it can
it can potentially guard us against such
adversaries
and the main theorem which is
which was uh obtained in a joint work
with oren mangubi
uh in 2021
is that if you're given access to a
function f
and to its gradient and hessian
um
we can from any initial point
find an epsilon greedy adversarial
equilibrium which is going to be defined
in the next slide
in
in in time which depends polynomially on
d
one over epsilon the d is a dimension
one over epsilon is the error
and b and l are some constants
associated to the function f
it doesn't make any assumptions on the
starting point
concavity coherence by linearity and so
on
we show that such an equilibrium
actually exists for every bounded
function with which scl
and if you're wondering what the
connection of this equilibrium is
to the
um
you know to the
to the case of uh
convex concave gains or convex concave
functions
uh we show that
the epsilon vdd equilibrium that our
algorithm will find
is also an epsilon global min max point
in in a technical sense
so um
so i don't know
uh
uh you know
what the plan for questions is but you
know uh
if you have anything that comes up uh
just feel free to interrupt me
but i can also take a
20 second break here to see if anybody
has any questions
before i go on to talk um
the talk is going to become a bit more
technical
um i had the question yeah hi hi hi
so uh i was just wondering about uh this
assumption that f is uh uniformly
bounded uh
by stop b
because uh
this wouldn't already hold like for for
some examples even of uh
convex uh concave problems so can you
comment a little bit more on that can we
just take this involved uh in a
neighborhood and then it is sufficient
or
how would you
so this is an important assumption and
uh you are right that we you know
this doesn't always hold
so the so the way uh
we can deal with it in the
in the case where
this doesn't hold
is to
have
some
bound on where the
solution lies where the global min max
solution lies suppose we have some idea
of a bounding box for this
and then we can restrict our function to
this bounding box
and that then will give us a bound on
how big the function can be
i see i see so if i'm understanding
correctly essentially if you initialize
close enough to a solution and you know
your function doesn't do anything crazy
and it wouldn't because it is uh that's
right
yeah i mean this is also for example if
you do gradient descent and then you
have to prove a convergence bound
um i guess there is some dependence on
the distance between the starting point
and the optimal point and the number of
iterations
all right
so
that makes sense so i'm not saying it is
the same but it's uh it's an important
assumption in the theorem and
at least in all
interesting cases this seems to be
obtained through an auxiliary analysis
yeah
thank you for the question excellent
question
okay so i will move on
and talk about greedy paths and our
definition of equilibrium
so the idea of greedy path is uh
really just what the word greedy paths
say so you are at some point let's say x
comma y
and
so let's say you are the mini min player
and you are trying to understand what
the y player can do
um so here is what you
here is a set of strategies you allow
the max or the y player to use
uh and of course none of this will work
if the y player is more powerful than
this but let me just say what the
strategy space is
so the strategy space is that y player
can go from y to w which is another
point in the space
as long as there is some path
from a continuous path uh from
you know that uh the
y to w
where
the derivative
of of the function is increasing and the
second derivative of the function
is also increasing and you know this
epsilon root epsilon
um is
is motivated by the nester of foliage
definition uh for this talk you can just
assume that this is positive both these
numbers are positive
but yeah if you want to get quantitative
bound just positivity is not enough and
we need these numbers to grow in a
specific
uh at a specific rate
so
so you can also just think of you know
if you want to model first order
algorithms then you can drop the second
condition
and
just require that the value of the you
know the rate of change of the value of
the function across this path is large
enough more than epsilon
and
you can see that this does uh uh you
know this this notion of greedy path
models uh you know some classes of first
and second order optimization algorithms
um
and so
um
yeah and and so
um
it is
it is restrictive it is more restrictive
than the general min max setting
but it might be useful
to to consider
if you are
not dealing with an all-powerful
adversary but something which itself has
access to algorithms
an efficient algorithm i mean after all
how will this adversary
uh
what will this adversary use
to
to
de-equilibrate the situation for the y
player for the x-player for the min
player
so this gives rise uh this definition
gives rise to a notion of uh well a new
function
which is what we call the g function so
the g function at the point x y
is the maximum value of f
where x is the same as the input to x
but the maximum is taken over all paths
starting from y
uh
which are which are reachable from y via
greedy paths
okay
so all g which are reachable from y
greedy path so so now if i look at this
picture here for illustration
suppose you are at this point a
so the point b seems to be reachable by
a greedy path
because you're always only increasing
there may be
non-greedy paths to reach here as well
but there is at least one greedy path to
each air
but this point c which is in this
picture the the true maximum
doesn't seem reachable so the adversary
if it wants to go from a to c
will have to incur some significant
losses before
it actually starts gaining
note that one of the key differences
between this
this notion and things like gda
is that we are not restricting how many
steps the adversary can take
and this becomes very important so maybe
the instability
or the cycling behavior was because we
were limiting
the
we were we were limiting in some sense
the adversary there as well by saying
the adversary can only look ahead so
much
so maybe there was a limit on some kind
of a memory of the adversary
or
uh yeah but but here we are we are not
restricting that
we are assuming the adversary to be
greedy and i think these kinds of models
uh and i'm sure there will there be
others might be interesting way to think
about
uh the problem where there is some
context and in that context
min max might not be
min mike's might be too strong
okay so
as a first attempt
we can define
now uh an equilibrium
for our framework
by extending the definition of nasrav
and poliak
it's a
in a pretty straightforward manner
so we have two functions
one is the gradient of f with respect to
y and one is the gradient of f with
respect to x
but we replace f with this greedy max
function
and we say that
a point x star y star is an epsilon a
equilibrium if
to y
and the hessian of f with respect to y
they are small
while at the same time
the
derivative of
g with respect to x and the hessian of g
with respect to x
uh behave in this manner so so even
though necessary of poliak defined only
for minimization i mean clearly it
implies
a similar local maximum definition
which is what we are using here
um
okay so
what is the problem with this
well there is a slight problem this
definition which involves taking a
supremum over all paths reachable from y
even though greedy paths
this function can be actually
discontinuous and this is not just some
side case but this can actually happen
so
we need one uh one get around and what
we do is we basically
smoothen the function so without going
into a lot of technical details
but if a function is not really
continuous one can smoothen it out
by
averaging it
uh
around the point by
doing a short random walk around that
point and just
associating that value
so that's what this function s does
it is some smoothening
of this function g
in the x variables
and there's also some technical reasons
for us to truncate the function
but let's not get into so many details
um but this is really it i mean this is
the this is the idea so if for whatever
reason the function g ended up being uh
uh
you know smooth itself continuous itself
then this is this is the definition so
once again so what did we do we
restricted the max player or the y
player to
just
greedy paths epsilon greedy paths second
order epsilon vd paths in this setting
and we used the definition of nasrav and
poliak we just plugged it in
in one case for the function f because
we are not really restricting the min
player so that's
it is what it is but since we are
restricting
the the y player we need to change the
function with respect to which we are
applying this definition of nastrov and
poliak
so
any questions about this definition
there was a question in chat by
imagine like he was asking like in the
initial paper smoothing
is is using like a randomized gaussian
convolution and do you see a way to
de-randomize the smoothing
well that's a that's a great question
and uh
um
[Music]
so in practice and in our you know in in
in this other paper that i will mention
at the end
um
[Music]
what
we do is
to actually
you know
maybe i'll answer this question in a
little bit more detail
once i introduce that but yes there are
possibilities to do that we don't want
to add a gaussian
in general so gaussian is nice to obtain
theoretical results
but
the issue with the gaussian is that it
leads to a polynomial and d dependence
in the running time and
that while in theory it is fine
in practice uh since most of
optimization is dimension independent or
depends logarithmically on the dependent
dimension that's not necessarily a great
thing to do so we must use somehow the
geometry of the problem
uh
when we are choosing this and
there may be some ways in which one can
potentially try to de-randomize although
currently
we don't know but you could imagine that
you could certainly reduce the
randomness by
looking at the
[Music]
you know for example if this was
instead of looking at the covariance
matrix which is just identity you could
look at a covariance matrix which is
obtained from taking the hessian of the
function at the point you are or some
lower dimensional version of the scn so
in practice you can do all kinds of fun
things
uh to obtain the same
effect but it's not yeah
it's uh it's not clear to me that
randomization is absolutely necessary
um
so i'm sorry i don't have a very
satisfactory answer to your question but
this is uh
this is a great direction to think about
okay so
how to minimize this function so that's
okay all this sounds great
you know what are we going to do with
this
so
yeah i think
maybe you want to see why you get some
feeling of why it may be discontinued as
well
for example if you start from this point
here xy
take a greedy path you might reach here
which is this side of the ridge
whereas from a close by point you might
reach actually a completely different
side of the ridge
so discontinuity comes in the sense that
when we perturb this point we can fall
here or there
uh anywhere
um
yeah so so this is uh
i mean even the landscape is very smooth
here
so it's not the issue of the landscape
actually it's the issue of the
definition
um
but this definition is robust for convex
concave function function is convex
or concave uh there is no problem it's
it's a it's a natural definition and
that is why we can kind of relate to the
results
in in the convex concave setting
so um
now how much time do i have uh i just
want to plan
the talk accordingly i think you can
still take uh five six more minutes
because we uh you know actually ten
minutes because we started the bitcoin
okay yeah okay i'll try to wrap up in 10
minutes thank you
yeah so
um
so
you know so so uh
you know forget the case of uh
smoothness i mean
or differentiability
even when g is differentiable
the function the way the function g is
defined it's a supremum over these
infinitely many paths
so how do we minimize this how do we
have access to gradient or or anything
so here we use an idea which is uh which
goes back to a very nice paper by
flaxman kalai and mcmahon from 2014
which allows us to
get estimates unbiased estimates of the
gradient
of a function
by
zeroth order access to it
so what we can do is to compute
you know
well let's see
i will talk about it in the next slide
but
uh let's assume for a moment we can
evaluate this function g
so then
this trick of flaxman kalai and
mahan allows us to
uh
compute the gradient
but now you may ask you know why can we
assume uh
yeah so you can kind of uh
um yeah and once you have access to this
uh
uh you know
uh
gradient you can run stochastic gradient
descent the only thing we do is to add
noise
uh this is to incorporate the
smoothening step in a stochastic manner
and we can show that noisy sgd returns
an epsilon local minimum
of this function for any given y hat in
poly in d
l b and one over epsilon steps
okay so
what does the algorithm look like
the algorithm
is iterative
there is some point x hat y hat
and
what it does is it keeps moving from
points x i y hat to some new point and
so that's really what happens it's an
input point x hat y hat and there's an
output point x y
so roughly speaking it
starting at x hat
first
makes a move for the min player so the
min player update its strategy
uh based on
its estimate of this greedy max function
the noisy greedy max function so that's
what is happening here so the x player
or the min player is
updating its strategy based on
its understanding of what the greedy
adversary can do
with some noise
and
it accepts that direction if it sees a
significant decrement in its value
so the min player is trying to minimize
so
it should not accept every move it
should accept moves which are reducing
its
objective value and in this case we will
we will
uh
we want the reduction to be significant
in the sense that it's at least poly one
over d and epsilon
and then once
x is updated the y player will run the
second order maximization algorithm
starting at y hat
to compute this new point
and this gives us a new point so this
does leave this issue
of how to compute g and that's something
i'm going to talk in the next slide and
that will be the last
technical slide i think in the talk
but
the proof is uh not too difficult
in fact it's
kind of uh the algorithm very carefully
has things which enable the proof
so roughly speaking i mean g decreases
by some non-trivial amount of poly one
over d epsilon amount at each iteration
and so if the function is bounded the
algorithm converges in this one
iterations and that's where we need very
crucially
an upper bound on the value of the
function
if there was no upper bound then we
can't say anything but if we know for
example what is some target upper bound
and we have some region
where we where we can kind of auxiliary
guarantee it we would be fine
if you reach a point where the x player
is unable to decrease the function g
then we can conclude that we reached a
greedy max for us so this x star
uh for for this uh
for for this smooth version of the
greedy max at this point y star
and we can show that the point
x star y star where our algorithm stops
is
this epsilon greedy
uh max that we were looking for so in
particular
it's
epsilon local min for the smooth g
function and
an epsilon local greedy max for the
function f
so one last obstacle which i want to
discuss is computing g
um
g as defined
is
a supremum over all possible
paths from x comma y
even though these paths only traverse
the y dimension they are allowed to
travel as long as the value on this path
is for y is increasing
and this
creates this very very huge and infinite
search space it's not clear
how to handle that
um and in general finding the maximum or
all these parts is certainly
interactable
so what we do is again simplify g to
some lower bound on g which we call this
function h
which is obtained by just
sampling one greedy path so out of all
the greedy paths that x you could take
from x comma y
uh all the y greedy paths that you could
take from x comma y the sample 1
and we show that this function or this
lower bound actually turns out to be
enough
for
for us
the details are not too difficult but i
think given i have two minutes i want to
skip
these details
but these are all the ideas uh i mean i
wanted to focus on the ideas in the talk
by giving some sense of what technically
is going on
i hope
you got this
so far
so now coming to the first order
algorithm um
with uh with vijay keswani or mangubi
and sushantera
we actually
considered a first order notion
which is
a simplification of what we considered
in this paper
where we would
only consider
will not consider the nester of poliak
equilibrium condition but the first
order condition which means that we only
restrict the gradient to be small but we
still restrict the y player to be only a
greedy player okay so it can only move
along
paths
[Music]
and we can show that
in this setting
we can get an algorithm which is uh
which is logarithmically dependent on
the dimension
um although the notion of equilibrium is
not as robust as the one that we
presented in this talk
but this is a paper which has a real
practical motivation so we it's very
fast it's running time in the end is
something comparable to gda
so we could compare our algorithm to
things like gda
and we observed
that our algorithm avoids cycling
and
shows
consistently shows improved multimodal
learning
um these are some
uh
i mean the paper this paper with uh okay
swanny mangubi and sister i have lots of
more
uh simulations on
on
synthetic and real world data sets in
case you want to look at
some of these pictures which i mentioned
where gda seems to fail
is uh our algorithm seems to be learning
multiple modes
so
so yeah i mean this does lead to
something useful in practice
okay so i'll conclude uh
the main
contribution of this work is
to consider
a restricted adversary in the min max
optimization framework a computationally
restrictive adversary
and this leads to
a polynomial time convergent algorithm
for
um
uh for for
for such you know for certain bounded
and lift [ __ ] functions
without any particular without any other
assumptions on the starting point
concavity and so on
um the notion does
naturally generalize
the setting of convex concave which has
been very well studied
uh the first order algorithm
has a weaker notion of equilibrium but a
faster notion of faster running time
and it also contains applications to
training gans
and i guess the main one of the main
open problems that remains
direct open problem that remains is
can the second order
greedy adversarial equilibrium be also
found in polylog degrading evaluations
so the nester of poliak result
uh
depended only logarithmically on d
whereas
our work depends polynomially on d
and the key obstacle to this is
this gaussian smoothing step
um
yeah so this is all i have to say thank
you so much for your time and attention
and
i'm happy to take questions
right thanks so much for the very
interesting talk
uh
i don't think you'll hear our plus but
yeah
right i personally find it's very
interesting for this notion of adversary
equilibrium and also this first order 3d
pass because i think in practice like a
lot of those adversarial attacks are
based on this first order dynamics so
this is for sure very interesting so i
think uh
man noy has a another follow-up question
about the unbounded domain as inina
pointed out earlier like he was curious
that
whether this would extend to whether
this would be robust to other like a
box constraint optimization etc yeah
yeah so that's uh
um yeah so one can restrict the
adversary
to
so so another way to deal with this is
to restrict the adversary
to making updates to greedy paths but
limiting how far they can go
and such notions have been considered
that where you would have a ball around
this point
the current point and you would say you
can go from here
to anywhere in this ball but that's
another way to bring in this
boundedness in some way
i would say
but that notion i mean the difference is
that
uh
the difference is that
you know so what we do we assume that
the function is bounded
but the y player can take
go as far as it likes
um
and
still there will be a point where things
can converge just having a ball
assumption on the on the y player
and the x player which is
what many local min max algorithms uh
optimization our frameworks try to do
uh still doesn't guarantee the existence
of a convergent
at least to the best of my knowledge
thank you yeah
are there any questions from the
audience
hi yeah
yeah i i just had another question
uh so so it's it's just uh related to
the
guarantee you you mentioned uh when you
use this
uh gaussian smoothing right so so the
guarantee for the main part uh if i
followed correctly is with respect to
the smoothed
version of the function
and
is it actually possible to also say
something about the guarantee with
respect to the original function i mean
my sense is
that
you know if your function doesn't look
too crazy and and uh you're
using kind of this small amount of
smoothing you're not going to erase
the local behavior okay so let me just
first try to make sure that i understood
your or your
question so if your question is
um that in this definition in this
yellow box here right the notion of
equilibrium is with respect to a
smoothened version of f
as opposed to as opposed to
uh just plugging in the function g here
is that correct
yeah yeah yeah so this uh yeah i think
this this seems like a issue because uh
uh like for example in these in these uh
even simple cases right where
the function g may be
pretty discontinuous so
i'm not sure we can give any guarantee
with respect to the g function itself
but if you made like some additional
assumptions like
you know that it is not discontinuous
but it is uh ellipses and and you know
the gradient can be discontinuous then
yeah so uh yeah that's
i think things like that can be done uh
the only thing i would say is that the
function g is not well it's a it's it's
a function which uh
you know it's a it's a function which is
defined from f
so
a condition on g uh doesn't necessarily
translate to any reasonable condition on
f what we are saying is that we have
this condition on f
yes if we make assumptions on g which is
like an intermediate function which
shows up we can also
get
and bounce yeah
so can you also comment on how big is uh
the dependence on these because your
slides mentioned polynomial dependence
on d but yeah specified oh i think it's
yeah i don't remember but i think the
the that's not uh unreasonable i mean
it's some small dependence but it's not
linear if that's
uh but it's probably quadratic or cubic
i don't remember
but it's yeah it's it's not a practical
algorithm this one
[Music]
because you know
it's even quadratic dependence on on
dimension
um
well i guess so what is the goal right
so the goal is that well we know
optimization has these powerful
algorithms gradient descent and so on
which are essentially at least
uh
explicitly independent of the dimension
of course dimension can come in in back
handed ways in the in the lipsticks
constant or other things but
there is still an option for you to run
the function you know done the
algorithm for a small number of
iterations and stuff
and given that d is large this
yeah this this doesn't seem like the
the
so some some directions uh that we are
uh you know to to to we are exploring
and something to think about is
um
i guess this takes us back to this
question that was asked before
that this d uh sorry this this function
f
uh
comprises i mean it comes from from from
data right so it's some sum of some
function f i's
where f i in turn is uh
you know
if i in turn is
uh
just dependent on a single data point
for instance and
one may ask that okay if the data has
some interesting geometry for example
if the data has some interesting
geometry
for example if all the gradients live in
some low dimensional space so maybe the
data is a manifold
where the tangent space is very small
dimensional
so it's
in those cases it is possible to speed
these things up
at least in the first hour case we have
shown that in the second order case uh
i guess we are still a little bit uh
stuck i would say
so niches there are also two other
questions i think one by jason one but i
know
yeah one question from jason is like
what is the difference of these new
notions this adversary equilibrium
comparing to the local min max or the
first order nash equilibrium which will
proven to be like p-pad complete i think
you mentioned this maybe yeah you can
elaborate that a bit more and then there
was another related question by law he
was asking like
in the convex concave or other settings
like uh
what is this epsilon greedy adversary
equilibrium comparing to the existing
like
comparing to the normal nash equilibrium
in those like convex concave settings
yeah yeah
okay so i'll answer jason's question
first
so in these uh
ppid hard results uh
you know
um again i must qualify by saying that i
haven't uh
[Music]
understood
you know the full implications of these
vpad hard results but
from what i understand i would say that
one of the key difference is that
the definition of greedy
paths
puts no restriction
on how far you can go from the current
point
whereas
in many of these hardness results
or non-existence results
one of the key sources of
hardness is the fact that the y player
cannot go too far
from where it is currently
um
but again you know i i would say that i
this is just my impression
there are real experts sitting there
who can probably
make more
educated remarks on this
and for the second question of noha
do you have a result from what epsilon
vd adversarial becomes
in the convex concave so i guess you're
asking
where the strong convexity doesn't hold
right is that correct
yes that that's right yeah
yeah
um
no actually i mean i don't think we have
thought very carefully about this
but i don't think we will
so okay so we
so i think the existence results
probably will still hold
but in terms of efficiency things will
need to depend on
the strong convexity in in our setting
so it's it's yeah i think
i shouldn't claim that this is a result
but i do remember
uh
talking
uh extensively with oren about this and
it seems like yeah we could prove some
mathematical results which says that if
you know things epsilon goes to zero
essentially and it's in the convex
concave case we will recover the
original
global min
max
solution space but yeah i i'm happy to
talk more offline about this
i don't want to speculate yeah all right
thanks so much i don't want to take you
more time i think there was one more
question but i think manoj will probably
like contact you of time and
we're going to have like 15 minutes
coffee break and we'll reconvene in 15
minutes and thanks again fish for the
very nice talk yeah thank you so much
bye